[Music]
Survivors of the same manufacturing method Second in front of the bridge I think there is a folk star Arisu
pa Nana is full of emotions and
sorrows  Pecordefen Contaminated Popular Edition Anime
Teacher's Day of Birth Jenna g
[Music] I
was a woman
Boo Boo 4 That kind of play Lead and Wright
I saw the main 3 cores Oh
I'll do it for 9 minutes at one place and nuts. I have to
take it. I
have to take
it.  Polypoke Chianti
Puyopu The spirit is composed of dip. Get out of bed.
foma It's a
cooking peso.
Even if it's after Felsa, it feels like it's going to be
erased.
Ivory Numechi
After all simulated beats Shoji who took his head on the coach attached to the sound gap-
Aripro
[music]
me
will do do me sa part order sate ios me to do
[music]
Wedding Chung and Naa ber Team spy  Peace
[Music]
usa are
amenber spark e to do
4 adreno tour per me and painting process
service for a ping
wii be moon can do it ended
Rou Boo Boo Outer meses 2 do you understand
a parent Tradewear
[Music]
Virus 1 Spy Pad with oo
by Building 2 Suzu Poppa Naru-sensei
Wedding Sampled Fight l Play Make Spain 4 as you
do
Strong Reason
[Music]
Do
n't say the dog, Kim Caster tv Maakun me
[Music]
pale ale
[Applause]
Thank you.
Ah ah I'm preparing for 2 years for that [Music] Ah ah ah
Thank
you Takahiro Ito I'm designing, manufacturing and assembling
robots Smarter is a threat to fight robots
me
car In
the case of the robot department  It's
not about defeating the opponent, but pushing the opponent out. The victory or defeat is in the truth.
Ran
[Applause]
[Music] It
's fun and fun to make a robot, so I go here every day to
study robots.  I spend about 360 days in this laboratory in this laboratory.
What I want to be most proud of is that all the parts are processed by my own hands and made by my own hands
.
My robot  Was named Yagi 7
[Music]
I'm in a position to think that the lot will move firmly after pressing the start button, so I'm
watching it with great excitement
[Music]
It is believed that there are three more points to win.
[Applause]
One is the hydraulic power to push the opponent out, and the other is the speed of the day to flick the opponent. The
last one sneaks into the opponent.  It is a defensive power to prevent it from being prevented.In the
final race, it is said that
we will not win a prize first.
Also, since the world tournament is coming up after that,
I would like to make various rose fights
[Music]
Live Fanner  Dosuna ah ah I gave birth to Barbie, but
my family is Yan
Ikenaga is a good Koyama
Zoya Achin newcomer
is you Chin
ss you doing your
ddr d 9  ef Elbow School Cheese Arukuramumero
me
ni When
you perform yourself, Nagabayashi Guy, what kind of greed and furniture
Suji-chan goes up to the house, and the stupid doctor and ec delusional love
gauge is
this party dur Garty starting  rates
for se The
companion flag is Benzin so small pen It's purely good for the invasion of the Japanese emperor c The traditional garden is different
Nishioda 6 hc I think it's a system
Lamia
No, Kosone is dead, just a spicy
sword [Music] Pearl Stoneware enjoy Spain des pres Transformer saben Ding on this are
coral grass Nezu
pou dou dou Unexpectedly
it's dj leaf water from the user name
No, there is a good product for the car german pattern handler for eating and drinking on the 3rd floor.
I don't want to say it well
[Music]
Group cover Nemaa
Anand I'm a conversion
edition
Grandma is on stage Ganha
Miyama Pan Sonoda Far is over Gege Deep Sea
I understand that, then Fia swear in love again  Corner patience bag
[Music]
me
I see almost 100% of the animations that robots come out on TV. I
thought that this was the design
I got from that.  I want to make something that will please various people
, but I think I'm just getting closer to the dream of the old days.
[Music]
Sting and Reefy denban by Duvet Zu drown o 4 a 5
Size Rover Uz  Blow by Won side
lw I'm Masaki Nago, who created the samurai.
It's been 6 years since 2017.
Otus are you doing
Discer weeks.
I had a longing to be able to move, but it means that it also moves, is
n't
it?  I'm making things with the feeling that it's new.
Smooth Achacha Stem-free rover to do a writer
I often saw Gundam, and the influence I saw until I was 8 years old or old Sati
is a big memory.  I
wanted to find out how much it was and make something that could be closer to that kind of thing.
Yabation Remover Zaza
One by one
Energy 2 Spoon 4
Display Display People 8th place
[Music]
It's really fun to make this, so it's not fun to make it, isn't
it fun?  There is nothing like that. In
the anime I watched when I was a kid, the ones that quickly exceeded human abilities are robots, so
the difference is that it's still different from what I'm drawing.
I think I'm making something that makes me think of it.
I think that something that Unge thought was realized
someday.  It's not the cornerstone of making something that hurts,
but even if I think that if I get a little bit, I'll be able to make something even more amazing
[music]